[Music]
entanglement have you guys seen this pop
up everywhere on Twitter and social
media me word it was with Will and Jada
oh I just saw something too today 50
cent was talking [ __ ] and he was like
[ __ ] you 50 that was like what is this
real
why why why is the word entanglement
news why is this okay
so context August Alsina August Alsina
he's a he's a music artist and so he
came out in this interview and revealed
some stuff or confirmed some stuff cuz
there have been rumors has he been
[ __ ] Jada you confirmed he was [ __ ]
data well I mean like isn't it like
pretty normal that were known that they
have an open relationship that's the
rumor but it was a rumor
yeah but the past 10 years I thought
they were open yeah I know I knew that
too but they were just saying like they
believe they believed in having a
lifelong partnership yeah but they're
still open well they never gave that
label yeah specifically I think cuz to
like save face for normal people that
can understand that that's true exactly
well also a lot of people who end up
being in like open relationships there's
different there's different ways of
perceiving what that actually means I
kinda actually define it and so that's
why for people that are in these types
of situations they have their own
version of how they're gonna be defining
it and so that's why for the Smiths it
just so like a lifelong partnership
well there's seven eleven open and then
this Japanese restaurant open we're
technically from three to five they
don't open that's true yeah they're
resting I don't know why they just open
for lunch and dinner I know they get
lazy or what and it's like 2:30 you
wanna have a late lunch you can't even
eat you know you got to start from five
I feel like that makes sense sometimes I
mean you could prep them while you're
working so this is what they've actually
said like a Chinese restaurant they're
cooking and they're eating at the same
time like for example back in 2013
Jada was
interviewed and she said when she
addressed this she said I've always told
will you can do whatever you want as
long as you can look at yourself in the
mirror and be okay because at the end of
the day will is his own man I'm here as
his partner but he is his own man he has
to decide who he wants to be and that
and that's not for me to do for him or
vice versa and then again she reiterated
reiterated in 2015 saying here's the
deal with that you've got to trust who
you're with and at the end of the day
I'm not here to be anybody's watcher
I'm not his watcher he's a grown man
here's what I trust I trust that the man
that will is is the man of integrity so
he's got all the freedom in the world as
long as we'll can look himself in the
mirror and be okay I'm good that's kind
of like how they've been addressing that
rumor but now myself in the mirror after
I get a [ __ ] though yeah I mean if
you're married and it's not by your wife
and you hold certain values maybe you
couldn't yeah that's true maybe yeah yes
a lot of gray area here I might feel
guilty or Welty I'll be looking
everybody everybody sorry anyway I'm
going to show you guys a video clip of
August during this interview and when he
confirmed during July Annie my life was
still relevant
I'd never eaten this is how you get
relevant heard of him before
is that a zodiac sign in the background
thinking it's a oh yeah looks like one
huh
strong to me huh yes okay anyway to
express my truth I actually sat down
with wealth and had a conversation due
to the transformation from their
marriage to life partnership that they
spoken on several times and it you know
not involving romanticism he gave me a
blessing to [ __ ] what I told me gave
myself to
that relationship for years of my life
you know and I truly and really really
deeply loved and have a ton of love for
her okay so that was what he said now
you know I don't know if you guys know
this but Jada she has her own Facebook
show called the red Tabletalk and that's
where I've seen clips of it yeah we've
actually talked about it here on on
Jackie news like war will willow where
willow would like talked about certain
things on that show anyway that's the
show that she has on Facebook and so she
said that she's taking herself to the
read table and and to have this talk and
so will was sitting and like the data
position so he was kind of like an
abuser and trying to like let her speak
her truth and so this is a clip from
that and what they say in it it went
very very viral I think I saw I mean cuz
this is your red tape when you like
brought yourself to the red table I
think you need to say clearly what
happened as far as what you and I
decided we were gonna take our space and
what happened
yeah and then I got into an entanglement
with August that's what I said an
entanglement yes absolutely I was in a
lot of pain and I was very broken so I
mean I'm in the Jada position right now
so you know you the during that time
launched into an interaction with August
what do you feel like you were looking
for I just wanted to feel good it had
been so long since I felt good I feel
like that husband like I'm with you at
the press conference my husband um but
now I gotta be with you at the press
conference while you'd like to tell the
world about your transgression
I love I love my baby I will stand by my
baby no matter what you expect to be
with somebody for a lifetime 25 years
and counting we ride together we know so
okay so the whole thing is like hell
this is just their situation that they
for many years it was kept very private
and so for her like they started off
this episode with them like Jada saying
like you know I was not very happy that
all of this like private information got
leaked out without like my knowledge or
whatever no the whole thing here is that
they have this life partnership thing
and she was in a relationship with
another guy and so it was it's not that
they're gonna get it at that time they
were separated they had broken up they
thought that they were gonna just end it
but then why her getting in that
relationship and apparently like they
ended up healing their own relationship
with them like their marriage but I
guess it's not a marriage yeah and so a
lot of people are looking at this and
from what I saw on social media it was
very 50/50 like half of the people are
like damn that's so tight like they're
so transparent like it's so real like
yeah people have different relationships
and people work out in different ways
and that they don't seem happy at all
like they're making it work for their
situation who the [ __ ] are we to judge
because we're not in this relationship
right
and so that's happy like one half and
then the other half is like like Jo like
they don't look like they're happy
that's terrible to say bad marriage for
life what the [ __ ] I would never want
that for myself like I would run far
away from that like how are they even
still together so there's like two
conversations happening around this
whole thing well I won't mind I mean at
the moment they don't look happy but I
don't know why like people could write
their own ideas of what the motive is
but for me it looks like embarrassment
because it seems like they're they've
been doing this forever but then now
they have to come out to the public with
it
so now it's embarrassing and it's kind
of like how are you gonna work through
this one now we [ __ ] blew the lid
didn't we you know like um we were
pointing out how well looked like he
just looked like a little hog man like
he like there are people pointing out
like there was just moments in this
whole episode where it looked like you
wanted to cry or like something was
going on behind the scenes that we
didn't fully get to see the station of
high-sodium these kind of bloated
well yeah it depends on how much you
know about their relationship cuz like I
didn't bat an eye about the infidelity
or and I don't even know if it's him but
the open relationship is because it's
something that I've heard and I knew and
I was like well they're probably dating
multiple people that's what I always
thought what what probably hurts is like
why did you do it it wasn't for pleasure
was actually because I'm empty feeling
with you you know and I think that's
pretty painful well that's cool that
they're talking about that I feel like
it's it's they're open and stuff like
they don't have to do it that way but
almost like why do people care so much
when it's a celebrity and their
relationship when it's like I think
that's important to understand of it's
like the idea of you even being
celebrity the be the reason why you even
have what you have is because of things
like your fans right you know I mean
when you're in that category of like
what is giving you success so it's kind
of like you owe it to your fans when the
whole world is talking about this if I
was will I'd be like yeah we got to talk
about this I at that side like being
like open and stuff I think in terms of
like how you conduct your relationship
especially because we don't get how it
is at that level you know like we don't
understand like the inside of the
relationship like no one ever knows
besides the two people literally inside
that you don't see for guidance yes so
when you shatter the when there's a
facade and you because for example like
Will Smith he's a stand-up dude like
well like what do you appear to be is
like they have great you know family
they have a you know great loving
relationship and then like what people
do is they use that as a beacon of hope
or whatever to model their life after
right and that's what people look at
when they see role models or celebrities
or whatever they go oh I want to be like
will or whatever and then this comes out
they're like it shatters their belief
and what they were chasing
so they're like what the [ __ ] I mean we
all know don't identify with a character
but we're not fans it's very different
from up from from the way that we see
behind the scenes and as an as a person
on stage it's very different for a
person that's looking up to someone on
stage I think it's good like the reason
they're talking about it because I'm
like it needs a shadow shadow those
things because people they have this
procession of what they're not no one's
a god yeah everyone's [ __ ] up yeah
it's like for them to go like everyone
has ups and downs yeah I saw that
they're going through it's one like on a
different level but it's like people go
through that you never have relationship
goals you know why because people are
only going to show you what is what they
want to show you yeah so when you look
at couples and you go oh goals it's like
why yeah you two literally don't know
what's happening you're doing the whole
ship unless you're inside the
relationship why do you want what
another person has it's like you don't
know you don't know if they're turning
around and beating each other up you
don't know if there's like other things
going on like it might be a give and
take they might have a lot of fun but
there might be a lot of things
underneath you know that's actually the
reason I realize that that that's kind
of what kind of developed my weird-ass
like social media phobia is it all
started like my journey like of my image
my public image right is the fact that
like early on a lot of people were
looking up to me and Casey and being
like oh my god you guys have the perfect
relationship you guys are so amazing on
all these things and then but like me
being inside the relationship I'm like
wait hold on we're not perfect like holy
[ __ ] there's so many issues like no no
we're not like this don't you guys show
a picture of a fight and then and then I
felt like a fraud it's all only the good
stuff no hold on so then I felt like a
fraud and so that's when I started like
revealing more and more and I'm just
like like it's not like that like I'm
not trying to be fake about my image I'm
not trying to give you guys these weird
like these uh Onate
yeah like unattainable illusion of what
our relationship is like because it's
not like that so then no but then once I
started revealing some of the truth it
ended up backfiring on me and then now
in like our relationship and then people
are like just scrutinizing our
relationship like why the [ __ ] are they
even married like it's so toxic like
things I find it I find it interesting
that like they only want to see the good
parts and then when you reveal like the
real three of your relationships it's
just kind of like welding you're the
idiot for being in the relationship so
then though then once that happened then
I'm like oh [ __ ] like I can't move I
can't make I can't show the good I can't
show the bad because no matter what it's
it's bad no matter what like I just it
kind of made me and made me feel in this
weird like frozen position that's why I
don't really blog as much I don't really
post as much I don't try to really talk
about our relationship that much anymore
on videos as much and it's just cause
like they're just really like weird like
I don't know how to navigate this whole
sense of like public image so seeing
Will and Jada in that episode it was
actually comforting cathartic yeah where
I'm like okay there's other people out
there that are similar option of who
cares what anyone thinks is like
obviously right but to actually feel
that is [ __ ] hard like to actually
get to that level and be like whatever
you know I'm slowly working towards that
and both case and I and like you know
like through therapy is very helpful
it's awesome they're desert going to
therapy yeah so then like slowly inching
towards that of like it is what it is in
Hawaiian yeah kind of like the goal and
yeah I think that that is a lot of
people don't think and work enough on
what happens like cause and effect so
what ends up happening is like you react
to the media feeling that you're getting
for example like if you if someone
passes judgment on you right instead of
dissecting how valid those person's
words are what you try to do is
immediately argue with them in your head
or
your heart whatever right and that's
what most people do so if someone made a
comment and you're just like wait that's
not who I am [ __ ] you right or you can
go who is this person let me look oh
this guy's like 14 he's never even been
in a relationship why is his words valid
why does it matter but if it hurts you
it's probably because you're insecure
about well that's exactly the work that
goes into getting to that point of who
it is what it is because that's what I
like
previously I remember mentioning on the
show or I'm like you know I started
reading comments and the ones that
actually affected me and like gave me an
emotional reaction I started analyzing
why does that hurt me why does it anger
me why do I feel like I need to correct
that thinking and it's because that's
[ __ ] that I just haven't dealt with
myself so it's like it's being projected
back onto me and I I don't know how to
handle like it's being confrontational
to you and you're like I'm not ready to
confront this [ __ ] right yeah and like
it's an egotistical like attack of like
trying to correct it even instead of
looking inside and being like oh [ __ ] I
don't when that's the key man is that
everyone's got this [ __ ] ego that
they don't know that they have everyone
thinks having an ego is being conceited
but that's not what it is it's literally
a defense mechanism yeah and you want to
preserve your identity and who you are
and what you think you are and all that
[ __ ]
and I'm like yeah and then once that
once you get to that point of it doesn't
[ __ ] matter because I can't control
what people think and do it's so
liberating and it's one of the best
feelings in the whole entire world I
think you need to like practice that
mentality because you have moments of
that where you feel good about it and if
you is balanced right if you have just
like your environment continues to
suffocate you even like just in small
doses over a long period of time right I
just think that people like sometimes
forget that even for example Will
Smith's first son wasn't even with Jade
it like that was already like oh yeah
because there's always a picture and
it's like those two and then some
grown-ass man they're like oh yeah so
you might be like looking at this
situation like oh my god like there's
supposed to be the perfect celebrity
family but it's like no like in context
imagine well like he's already gone
through maybe one marriage and you know
having a child with somebody
things didn't work out I mean he didn't
like that feeling you know what I'm
saying
maybe he who's going through some stuff
with Jada and it's kind of like yo like
to be honest even just to be around for
Jaden and Willow or to blah blah blah
let's just this be a partnership but but
respect each other that's no you don't
understand look I look at it and I'm
like this is this is great you know sure
some some August's else comes out but
the fact that they're gonna empower
themselves out of this Jada and will
like the powerful people they're they're
really powerful they're they're you know
they're human so there are gonna be
moments where they can be honest and say
things like you know I was hurting and I
need you to feel good that's the most
[ __ ] honest Nia that I could hear
somebody say as a celebrity sitting
across from their husband knowing the
cameras right there and being real you
know what I mean I'm like and for him
regardless the tears are not for him to
sit there and I'll be able to talk about
I think that's [ __ ] awesome yeah
because like that infidelity or whatever
like that's just a human thing you don't
have to be a celebrity to experience the
things that they're going through and
why do we care whose dick whose sucker
I feel more bad for the guy choosing red
hair I rather be crying I swear I'm
[ __ ] that red-haired audience I don't
know why he talked about though exactly
maybe he want to close the recent yeah
maybe he wanted I don't know pressured
Jada said that this relationship was
like for know him talking about it oh
yeah oh why does even have to bring it
up that's why they were kind of like
caught off guard they were just like why
now this is something we've dealt with
years ago so he's probably bringing it
up as like a badge of honor it's an ego
thing you know well in another interview
that I had read apparently August had
come into their life at that particular
time and he was like I guess mentally
ill or just needed help so like they
were like helping him you know bruising
and all that and I guess the
relationship had developed into
something more you do see a healing
though yeah getting laid is healing
maybe that's what brought him back to
reality Jada got some [ __ ] medicinal
color oh yeah what if if you say so it's
a conversation with him and will 50 said
yo well you all right over there
yes I'm cool I appreciate your concern
my brother and 50 says but why should
tell you that [ __ ] on a show for
everybody to see and will says we broke
up so she did her and I did me and 50
says then she said only she can get
permission for somebody to blow her back
out and then who will goes [ __ ] you 5000
like what did I do
[Music]